what
look i'll do work overalls but i'm still
gonna wear this jacket
[Music]
the caretaker
and i know i've done some complaints
as we've gone into series eight so far
here and there but they've mostly been
complaints with some high points like
i complained quite a bit about listen
but i also pointed out some of the
things that were really good whether
they be core ideas or really good
moments this this feels like one of the
first episodes that
there isn't a lot to recommend it i
don't think it's awful
necessarily and i'm not even sure i'd go
so far as to call it
bad i think it's unremarkable
for me personally it registers is worse
than that because it plays into some
things that i just don't like when they
get applied to doctor who
and a lot of that has to do with tone
this thing in a lot of ways and this had
never occurred to me before maybe
mainly because i don't really think
about this episode as
a as a general rule of thumb but
it occurred to me that tonally it
feels a lot like the lodger the
matt smith and james corden episode the
first one
uh that they were in together it has
that vibe
on multiple levels in terms of the
doctor
in an environment that he's obviously
not totally comfortable in
trying to be normal while tracking down
an
alien something or other and it also
this is going to be a weird nitpick for
me i also hated the music and it
reminded me of the music
uh from a lot of the larger as well i
rarely complain about marigold's music i
think mario gold did very good work
but there are some times when
he goes for this light bouncy and
it's not even like light-hearted but
like
kind of sound it it reminds me of like
the kind of music
that john williams makes when he's
soundtracking characters like jar jar
binks it's that kind of music
he uses in the lodger he uses it here he
actually uses it for
donna noble's score as well which i
don't i also
don't like it's about the only thing i
don't like about don i don't like
the recurring theme they were using for
i i didn't like it at all
so i don't like the music in this which
is a rare complaint for me
um it's yeah that just doesn't work
and there's just a lot of bits and
that just don't come together some of
them the major relevant
elements some of them relatively minor
that said it starts out well the opening
sort of
montage of clara juggling
being with the doctor trying to have a
home life
is actually kind of interesting and i
think it's pretty well done
as an introduction to get a sense of
what a day for her is like and this sort
of
leading a double life in the most
literal sense because
she's basically having a full day with
the doctor and a full day
you know trying to be with danny and
tc's kids or whatever
back to back on a fairly regular basis
and i think that did a good job of of
displaying that and showing that
and i dug that i that was that was a
good opening
i wish that that kind of
vibe had had held throughout instead we
get weird awkward humor like the doctor
misconstruing who clara's dating and
and we also have the recurrence
of the the patronizing
and the belittling of soldiers which i
brought up in into the dalek where it
got seated
and i'd forgotten
how mean
the doctor is to danny and
again let's be clear this doctor is
grouchy
as a rule he's grouchy towards everybody
but like
if you want to contrast the difference
between being grouchy and being mean
look at how he talks to courtney woods
the
the girl who comes in and like he has
some interactions with
and later and towards the end of the
episode he actually takes in the tardis
and how he acts towards danny pink
one is dismissive not really taking her
feelings into account
treating her like she doesn't matter all
that much and the
other is being actively cruel and
mean towards somebody and there is a
difference
there and i i don't like it i will
continue to argue that it doesn't track
and they haven't accounted for it
properly
i get the doctor being skeptical of
military at all i get the doctor
absolutely being fearful of anyone who
is going to be armed with a gun
who is likely to have a first response
of pulling that gun out and using it
i get that but danny is not
currently in the military
he was a soldier he is now a teacher
he doesn't currently currently have a
commander he doesn't currently have a
gun he has chosen a different way of
life and even though i can buy the
doctor being skeptical of
soldiers and the military in general
because of how it tends to exacerbate
the sorts of situations he finds himself
in
he's still worked with military people
he knows that they are capable of being
good rational people and doing the right
things or that they can at least be
talked into doing the right things
we have seen him across classic and new
who
do that with various characters from the
brigadier
to ross and the sontaran two-parter
which are already cited to
his own daughter jenny who he initially
dismisses
because not just because that she's a
soldier but because she pops out of a
machine
literally designed to be nothing but
that
i get that the doctor is dismissive
or cautious or just
unsettled by soldiers
i'm not okay with the doctor
deciding that well that is all they are
that is all i will consider them to be
he's not even a currently soldier i
don't care
he was one once for the doctor to start
taking it to that level first of all i
just
don't enjoy watching that i don't
appreciate it
and in addition to that i do feel given
the character's history across other
regenerations
with interactions with the military you
need to justify it if it's going to be
that deep run that he will behave that
way even towards someone
who is no longer actively serving heck
wilf was in the army and yes it gets
established that wolf never actually
shot anybody
but he was still a soldier he still
joined up he still was trained
the doctor didn't treat him like crap
for that fact
he doesn't know whether danny ever shot
anybody he wasn't that little annoying
kid who asked that question
i'm dwelling on this right it really
irks the crap out of me
how that entire element was handled and
again
i understand why it's there in terms of
the doctor coming to terms you know
having an initial clash with who
clara is dating and where danny pink's
story goes in the end
so i'm not even gonna say that it isn't
worth it doesn't pay off in some way but
i just hate the way this is handled
initially
i really do and i've spent way more time
talking about it than
than i probably should so let's let's
move on
so i'm just gonna at this point i'm just
mainly gonna be listing things that
also didn't work there's gonna be a
handful of things that i kind of liked
and a lot of things that
both small and big that just don't work
for me
in this episode there's some weird stuff
like with
the tech going on like did i miss before
did clara ever snap open the tardis
doors before because
her just doing that casually i don't
like that
like that's not something a campaign
should be able to do and i and i know
like clara's
more entwined in his timeline and
everything and also moffat was so
clearly in love with clara that she's
the most
amazing companion person ever and of
course she can do things that
that normally only the doctor could do
or actually not even the doctor himself
could do until his tenth freaking
incarnation
but whatever since when
that invisibility watch that was kind of
a dumb idea
i well i'll backtrack it's not a bad
idea in
episode and it's actually used fairly
decently i like the idea that
clara sneaks danny onto the tardis so
that he can hear
clara the doctor interacting the doctor
knows he's there right off i actually
kind of like the use of it but
just as a thing that exists that's an
overpowered piece of tech
which never comes up again because it
can't because if the doctor could just
literally turn himself invisible
whenever the heck he wanted
like that would that would be possibly
even more overpowered than the sonic
screwdriver
so the fact that that gets introduced in
in this like at all i'm just like uh
no the design for the creature the
blitzer doesn't
quite work there's i think there's
something overly
stiff about the movements of the lower
half and some
and the upper half is a bit more organic
with his movements
and i i suppose that could be more
complementary in terms of like uh
you could almost get something
unsettling with feeling like the upper
and lower halves are almost thinking
independently but like
it's like it's on rails the way that
thing is shown moving across
the floor they're probably trying to
make it look efficient but it just looks
like a really
stiff realization and that
that doesn't quite work oh also what is
it with
and this is not unique even to doctor
who but what is it with
evil robots or alien robots or
pieces of technology always announcing
what they're doing
[Music]
helicon incoming commence retargeting
scanning targeting destroy
like look i'll give the daleks a pass on
exterminate because
like that's not just something they're
doing that's a life
philosophy for them but like
what is it with with robots that are
like
just announcing loudly everything that
they're doing why would you design a
machine
to do that i know why it's so that the
audience knows what they're doing but
you know what
we're not that dumb uh i mentioned the
romantic
the misunderstandings before which is
just it's
like that's that's the kind of nonsense
i hate that that kind of nonsense is why
i hate romantic subplots most of the
time
so uh um i actually kind of like
the introduction of courtney woods i
actually kind of like the feeling the
vibe she has with the doctor
i kind of like that he takes her just to
see
him dispose of this thing and she throws
up i don't know why like i can't really
justify that
i can't actually say that that was a
good idea or a good mover that she
benefits like
there's nothing that i can explain why i
like it i just kind of do
i think it's just the chemistry between
her and capaldi
kind of works in this episode so i'm all
right with that
i do like that clara
really does pull out the uh what i'm
just going to call the big teacher
energy
um with with the doctor when interacting
with him when he
really frustrates her she just like
my partner liz is an educator and
it and it's not that far from like stern
parent voice
but you know because with educators it's
not your own kid so you have to like you
have to
bottle up a little bit more tell
everybody like oh no
no you listen to me right now and i like
when she brings that energy
to to her interactions into the doctor
which is another way that
making her a teacher has bled over into
her characterization in a
positive way it's a good thing i wish
she had been more
just fully characterized when she was
introduced in series seven
but whatever and yet at the same time
she tries to pull
this whole thing oh it's a play or
hersey you're a player
what how stupid you think i am like
thank god danny doesn't believe her even
for an instant but like
the fact that that ev that joke even
went on
for as long as it did or for longer than
two seconds honestly for longer than the
line
it's a play the fact that it wasn't
immediately shut down
after that it just feels insulting to me
and oh finally look i know danny's a
soldier or was since when does soldier
mean
gymnast or parkour
excuse me i buy that he's in good
physical shape
but that thing was like six feet tall
and he jumps over it and flips over it
uh
i i wish i could say that that it shows
a high respect for
the uh abilities of a soldier but that
just seems to not
not understand you know
what the skill set of a soldier would be
uh i think that's it
this thing is just clunky it's just
clunky it doesn't come together now if
you enjoy this kind of vibe
the sort of more lighter bouncy
kind of kind of not particularly serious
clear from the tone that we're not
taking things all that seriously
and we're doing really low stakes even
though we say it's going to destroy the
world like
don't worry about it kind of vibe that
it's going for
with the romantic comedy style elements
maybe you'll get more out of this but i
can't imagine this is anything that
anyone is going oh it's such an
underrated episode i love it although
knowing me i'll still get a couple
comments that actually say that
i don't get it i just i just don't
and there's there's so many small things
that are just infuriating about this
thing
the caretaker you rewatched it lately
what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff to do you know
what it is like
and subscribe and all those things i
have a patreon
all the more important these days i'm
not employed anymore
but you know there's that and links to
social media and all sorts of stuff
check them out give them a look or don't
don't sweat it it's not that big a deal
because i can't tell you what to do end
of the day
you're the council i just from the
meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh